Hi and welcome back to another
VC libraries Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at a PR from
our contributor superwog implementing
new algorithms for the C23 standard.
The paper number is
P1223R5 and the algorithms are find last Umm,
and there's a whole family of them.
The PR that we're looking at in the
Microsoft SQL Repo is 3268, so here's the PR.
This has a link to the
tracking issue that we filed,
um which lists the feature test
macro that should be implemented.
And here is where we link to all of
the relevant papers that were voted in.
Sometimes there's a primary paper and
then patch papers that update it later,
sometimes LWG issues from the
library working group.
In this case, there's just one paper.
And here I've opened it up
to see what wording it has,
and then finally I've opened up
the currency versus working draft
with the current standard's.
I don't believe this has been
patched by anything later,
but when a paper just adds a whole bunch
of new wording and doesn't have like.
Lots of fine grained changes
to existing wording.
It can just be simpler to look at the, uh,
the final version in the working draft.
So we've got the features macro here.
These algorithms are there's
a little bit of interesting.
Detail about how they work with,
um, uh,
forward versus bidirectional
iterators let me actually see
where the wordings being added so.
Here is the.
Post wording. This is just the
context where it's being added.
The new stuff highlighted
in cyan here is find last.
So we get find last, find last if taking
a predicate and then find last if not,
and then the actual addition is
in a section named Alec find last.
And that's it. OK,
so there's no aside from the synopsis change,
which is just declarations, there's no other.
Changes to existing standard's so we
can just look at the working draft now.
I've already found the relevant section.
This is a. It looks like a whole, you know,
dense mass of keywords and identifiers.
It's not as frightening as it May 1st seem.
It's just because this
is specifying both the.
Predicate forms and the non the
inverted form find last if not,
and so forth.
And it's got 2 forms to handle
iterators and Sentinels and ranges,
because C plus doesn't provide us
a way to sort of unify these in
just a single combined declaration.
But it's not quite as complicated
as it seems.
So let's take a look at the PR
and then as we see,
interesting things all refer back
to the standard's. Me magnify this.
OK alt Click to on the Chevron to
see what files are being added.
So we are updating our central internal
header to mention the new paper and
the feature test macro product code
changes in the algorithm header.
We have new test being added and
then a feature to smacker test.
Ever since I was in kindergarten,
I like to eat my dessert first,
so I'm going to look at the
easy changes first.
Here is the new declaration
or the new list of the paper.
Let's make sure it matches
the tracking issue. It does.
This makes sure that there's no typos
or digit transpositions in the paper number.
So that's good.
This is in sorted order and is
this being listed under C23?
It is.
That's good.
And then we've got the feature test macro.
So here's an interesting bit where I
originally recorded CPP Lib find last,
but the feature just macro is
actually going to be named ranges.
And last and here super wig has
added a comment that there's a
library working group issue,
so I'm gonna use my search shortcut.
I just type LWG and this takes
me right to the issue.
So the paper this was actually
opened by Super Rick, thank you.
The original paper specifies
CPP Lib find glass,
but it's only adding ranges algorithms.
So for consistency it really
should be named ranges find land.
So this is already been approved
by the library working group.
It will be voted in during the next meeting.
Totally fine to implement it
now by convention.
We'll comment when we're
sort of implementing things.
A little bit advance of the standard,
so commenting LWG 3807 here is appropriate.
So range is fine.
Last and the value is 202207.
That has not changed.
Um, so this looks cracked.
Yep CPP Lib Brain just fine.
Last that's sorted order LG 3807.
Double check that this is correctly and
see what was 23 and not say C + + 20.
Correct. OK, which is good.
Let's take a look at the feature
to smacker test.
Uh, we've got the new ranges.
Find last. I will check that value.
Ah, we've got a typo.
OK,
so this is.
This is why I habitually search for
all occurrences of the value to detect.
Copy paste those in this case,
because this stuff is so repetitive,
the the usual way to add it is copy pasting,
but one of these was not updated.
Where we emitted an error,
but this says a different value,
so that's a bug.
This uh value.
Because I'll just say it's incorrect.
OK, because I expect to see it
three times repeated exactly.
I'm assuming that the spelling is
correct because this would fail
if it were spelled incorrectly.
But for completeness, let's double check.
OK, so all of these were updated.
Occasionally I will find like a
copy paste error where one of these
macro occurrences was not updated,
but here they're all good.
Let's see. Jose asked in the chat.
Can we script these repetitive sections?
That would be nice.
Unfortunately, the preprocessor does not
really have any advanced logic for doing so.
In theory, we could write an
actual script that would emit code,
but then we would need like a build
step in the test machinery to run
that script to generate a source file.
And ultimately it would just be sort
of the the stuff that would drive
that script would be kind of repeating
the just sort of the the declarative
list of macros and values here.
So ultimately I don't know of
a better way to do it.
This is just sort of repeating
information twice in different ways to
make sure that we detect any divergence.
In uh in in theory I mean this test.
This test was originally um,
and it's an interesting question.
This test was originally added for both
the compiler and the Standard library.
When I went into the compiler and
pretended to be a compiler dev for a day
and added feature to smacker support,
it was testing the compilers expansion,
which could go wrong in all sorts of ways.
The library macros have always been simpler.
We just define them or we don't
and we set them to various values.
So ever since.
We carved up this test into half and
then sent the compiler part back
to the compiler.
That's in the internal test harness.
Now,
the library part of the harness
is admittedly not providing super
duper useful coverage.
We probably could just eliminate this
task and wouldn't lose a whole lot.
We would need to be extra careful
to make sure that we're guarding
things and the header properly.
But there's not a whole lot of
ways that this can be damaged.
I suppose it does provide a useful check
to express things in different ways,
so this tells us.
We should only expect to see find last
when 23 and CPP Lib concepts are enabled.
This is implied by the structure
of the header,
but expressed in a different way because
it's guarded by of 23 and concepts.
O if we tried to script this,
the stuff driving it would end up
looking more like rivals Core H um.
So would, I think,
actually reduce the utility of
the test a little and in addition
to significantly complicating the
the test machinery.
But perhaps there's a more elegant
way to do it, I'm not sure.
OK, so returning here.
So we've got the macro name
spelled correctly.
We've commented about the value
not occurring here.
Does everything else look good?
We are indeed guarded by if has
23 and defines eclip concepts.
Here I'm just checking for all the
underscores and capitals being correct.
We've got this comment because
hopefully we won't always need to
be checking for concepts.
There's a tracking issue about that.
There's also a comment about LBG 3807.
Totally reasonable here.
Once that's accepted and working paper,
we'll go back and eliminate all
these comments.
Um,
last thing to check is is it actually in
sorted order?
Um, ranges contains ranges,
find ranges, fold. Yes it is.
OK, so this looks good.
OK, I'm continuing.
Easy to miss because this is only
used by the internal test harness.
Um. This is incorrect.
Um, it appears that these directories
were added and then the name
was updated to add the ranges.
Alec for consistency with our other tests.
But then test dot list was not updated.
So this works in the GitHub harness because
the Python powered machinery will just
recurse and find all the directories.
But in our internal,
much less advanced Earl power to harness,
I cringe when I say that.
Um, these directories just won't exist
and I think it will emit an error
or it will just silently skip them.
In any event, this needs to be updated.
These test directory names are outdated.
This is absolutely something
that could be scripted,
but we would have to descend into
Pearl Madness to fix this and we just
have never actually had the time.
In the future, I hope that we
will be able to get the internal
machinery to run to drive the,
uh, Python power test harness.
That would require a fair amount of
engineering work, but we would be able
to eliminate all this legacy stuff.
It's on our it's on our To Do List.
We've got a project for completing more
of the GitHub migration and getting
rid of our internal legacy stuff.
OK, so comment there.
I'm aside from that, at least the,
UM, the paper number is OK.
I will check.
That is what the the guiding principle
here that I'm not voicing until now is
that when I find something like a typo,
sort of, my level of caution
immediately goes up a notch.
I start looking for care.
There other typos or copy paste errors,
things like that.
Because where there's one,
there's usually more.
So paper number is correct,
so we just need to correct the
directories and it is inserted order.
Another thing we don't
algorithmically enforce. OK, good.
Uh, we've got configuration files.
Let's look at these first.
Uh,
we always need our copyright
license banner here.
I have a personal tudu to maybe add
some scripting to validate that each
of our files has the banner here.
These need concepts because they're
powered by ranges and it's a 23 feature,
so we need the latest.
These matrices have sets of compiler
options that we throw at each test.
So concepts latest matrix is
correct and we do permit the.
Permissive mode.
So the absence of strict here is good.
It increases our test coverage,
so concepts latest each time.
This is all good.
I'll come back to the test files
just checking that each of them
have the banner before I forget.
Yes, OK, that's all good, we'll come back.
OK, let's actually look at the algorithm now.
OK, so before I get to the algorithm,
let's take a quick look.
Let me close this at the working
paper UM to give a quick overview
of what these ranges algorithms do.
OK, so, um, sort of the
fundamental ones are find last.
So there are six of them here
because it's covering find glass,
find last, find last.
If not, that's three of them times Iterator,
Sentinel versus.
Take an entire range at a time. Um,
but really the core algorithm is just fine.
Last, so the reason why we have find
less if and then finally if not.
This is very similar to the
classic design of the STL.
So let me change to.
I guess I can just scroll up to find the
existing ones because the the classic
signatures that don't take range of
stuff are sort of simpler to look at.
So here is classic STL find versus find if.
So there is a reason why find and
find if are named differently.
One takes a range of iterators and
looks for a specific value and
is going to use operator equal
equal to see hey are you equal.
The other one takes a predicate,
a function object.
Returns the first element it can find
where the predicate returns true.
These are differently named because,
especially in the classic C + 98 era,
the STL could not sense whether
something given is a value that's
intended to be used with a quality
or a function object that's
invocable with operator in front.
You could even imagine pathological
scenarios where you've got an object
that's comparable with equality to the
element type and it has a function.
All operator that accepts the element type.
There's nothing stopping such
a strange thing from existing.
So in theory there is no actual way to
distinguish the programmer's intent,
and that's why these have separate
names and are not just overloaded.
Sort of less defensible in the modern era,
but it did need to exist.
Back in the classic era.
Is the negated form find.
If not,
this takes a predicate but then returns
the first one where it returns false.
So the STL in C + 98.
Decided to provide these,
not versions because they were,
you know,
sort of simple defined in the
algorithm and it didn't require
creating a reversed predicate or
wrapping the predicate in a negator.
The classic SDL did have.
A helper machinery to negate
the results of predicates.
But it was sort of hard use.
Um, not generally applicable.
Um.
And it was just a pain to use.
So although I'm not 100% sure
of the design rationale,
I believe that these not algorithms
exist because the negator machinery
was not as useful as one would hope.
That is actually changed.
We now have something in C going off a
little bit of a tangent on cppreference,
not fun.
We now have a generalized negator wrapper.
Or you can give it a functor and
a callable object and it will
return something that will invoke
that thing and then apply operator
or not and return the opposite.
It's opposite,
stay or because in C plus we can
now use lambdas.
It's if you're gonna provide a Lambda,
it's easy to just write a Lambda and put
the exclamation mark character in there.
So I would say that in the modern
era and C + 23 there is much less of
a reason to provide not algorithms
and I imagine library evolution.
We've talked about this um,
but currently it is following
the Convention of hey,
if you have an if algorithm,
also provide a not algorithm because
otherwise it could become a frequently
asked question where somebody says,
oh if I have you know,
find if and find if not how come there's no,
you know, find last if and
find last if not counterpart.
So it provided 6 algorithms instead of four.
Even though possibly in the modern
era we don't really need these,
it's not really much trouble
for us to define. Um,
if we were gonna create a completely new STL,
we probably wouldn't have
the the NOT versions.
But that's why these exist.
And then according to the ranges system,
there are now these projections which allow
you to view range of elements through a lens.
They are projected.
According to some function object or
call by object by default just identity,
so by default it does nothing.
But occasionally it can be useful to say,
OK, I've got a range of elements,
maybe strings,
and I want to find the first
one that is bigger than.
Or find the last one, um,
with a length of, you know, uh,
larger than 16 characters or something.
So I'd like to project the string to just
its size before invoking some predicate,
like a Lambda that looks just at the size.
This can be more useful than having to
bake that projection into the predicate.
And it's especially useful when
you're using the value form because
you could say if you wanted to,
say, find the last empty string,
you could say, find last,
project the size, and then just look for.
Ro as the value rather than find
last if and then test the size again.
Zero different ways of expressing
the same thing,
so that's what the projection is doing.
Umm, and so this wording um says uh,
it it handles sort of the
differences between these um,
value versus predicate versus
negated predicate form,
saying the value form uses operator equal,
the predicate form will invoke.
This is the invoke protocol that we've
talked about in previous code review videos,
which will handle the syntax differences
between things like function pointers,
member member data pointers,
and call objects or function objects like.
Lambdas and then the negated
form says operator not there.
And what this returns is the
last iterator in the range for
which this expression is true,
and if it doesn't find anything,
it will return just the last iterator.
Bringing the range algorithms
also return a sub range.
Um, so.
If you have a input range,
it will return the answer as a range,
which can be useful when
chaining these sort of things.
And there's a complexity requirement
that we don't invoke the predicate
and projection more than the
number of elements in the range.
That says basically, no repeated tests,
you get a test each thing exactly once,
no more than once.
And then the other interesting thing,
which I alluded to at the
beginning of this code review,
is that these algorithms
take forward iterators,
but it talks about returning
the last iterator in the range.
So as we go to the implementation,
we're going to see something interesting
because if you have bidirectional
iterators or stronger like random
access or contiguous iterators,
if you want to find the last element in the
range that satisfies a predicate or value,
you can just March backwards.
From the end,
the last iterator and as soon as
you find something then you say
hey I found the last one done.
But if the user gives you
a forward only iterator,
like a forward listed or forward
list Iterator,
a singly linked list,
then you have no choice but to
March from the beginning because
you can't ever go backwards.
So the algorithm there would be search
from the beginning of the list or sequence,
as soon as you find something,
remember where it is,
but then keep going onwards and
as soon as you find another value.
Toward that as the last value you found,
and so on,
and then when you're done,
return the last one you saw.
Of course you must traverse every
single element in the list,
but that's the best you can do
with forward only iterators,
and there could be use cases for that.
Nice to have the STL do this for
you rather than having to call
a whole separate algorithm or
write something from scratch.
But in the case where The thing is not found,
in the case when The thing is not found,
it's same complexity either way,
when it is found,
the forward version is to traverse
basically all the elements,
whereas the bidirectional version
is order length of the distance
from the end to that element.
So that's why it says forward iterator.
It does not accept input iterators
because and the STL forward iterator
means you can March forward,
but you can also preserve iterators
to an element and dereference
it as much as you like and it's
going to still be there.
It's multi readable.
Conceptually,
this means that four iterators point to
something in memory that's persistent,
like a singly linked list.
Whereas input iterators are
something like from an input stream,
an I stream where you can consume
something from the stream and look at it,
but then if you advance the iterator,
that existing value evaporates.
It was just returned to you,
but it's not existing anywhere
persistent in memory.
So an input iterator is a input
iterator algorithm is a single pass.
Algorithm.
You don't get to do something
like preserve an
iterator March forward and then
look at the previous value.
So that's why this must insist on forward
iterators and nothing weaker than that.
OK, so, um, that's sort of the overview
of what these algorithms are doing.
Let's actually look at the code.
OK, so we are updating the algorithm header.
I'm going to look at the context to
make sure that we are in a C23 zone.
I can see we're calling fold right here,
so I'm almost certain we are.
And I just.
Expand. If I get bored, I might
just open up the STL in VS code
because we've got a lot of C23 stuff.
Yeah, that's taking too long.
Let's just open up the STL.
Um, OK and actually I can
just check out this PR.
Uh what number is this 3268.
Use the GitHub command line tool DHCR.
Checkout 3268.
Great. And then we want to look at,
now that I've expanded all this,
I want to unexpand. There's no button
to immediately do that. Whoops.
OK. Here's where the code begins.
I could dip against main,
but I can here. I just want to
search for this find less fun. OK.
That's on line 2801.
You'll be the guard.
OK, it was actually 600 lines
above where um starts with fun um.
OK, so we are in a C + 23 zone.
Uh, I guess I could look for the next
end if to be super duper careful.
I kind of wish it wouldn't immediately
navigate me as soon as I type something,
because I want to see where I was.
OK. Yeah, we and then.
In fact it ends after the new algorithm,
so if I Scroll down I could find it.
I can just do that here. Yes.
OK, so we are adding to A to
an existing HASC X23 region.
So that's good.
I checked this because nothing will complain
if we add something to a too old mode.
Like if we added this to C20 and
we didn't depend on something
that was specifically C + 23,
that would compile,
and yet we would be defining these
identifiers in a mode that they
really shouldn't exist in yet.
OK, so we're adding to the correct region,
so we're going to define a class because.
These things in the standard that look
like functions are actually function
objects in the ranges universe,
which handles, I think,
argument dependent lookup.
It means that they're not subject to ADL,
which is nice, it's just a new design.
And that means that what looks like 2
functions in the STL for each of these
forms is actually just two operator
overloads of a single function object.
The other thing I'm going to verify
before I look at anything else is
that we are respecting modules.
After adding 3000 occurrences of
the macro export stood to the STL.
Now we just need to make sure that
all new user visible identifiers
are marked as exported.
So the Convention here,
the way it works is that the user
visible object is marked as export.
We do not need to export the internal
class or any of the function call
operators or anything like that.
So for these three overloaded functions
we mark as export and here it is.
And the objects O exports did find
last exports stood find last if
and export stood find last if not.
We don't specifically need
modules coverage of this.
Our modules test tests a
little bit of every STL header,
but does not go so far as to test
every single algorithm with every you
know possible iterator combination.
That would take years and years to write,
so here just spot checking that
all of them are marked as export
stood is sufficient.
OK, so let's actually look at this class.
So we derive from our internal helper.
Not quite object.
Then we have public machinery and
operator pren prens we need to use
inheriting constructors from it.
This means that users can't like
default construct this object thing.
That's what it's not quite
object machinery does.
Let me actually split this so I can at
least look at the signature real quick.
OK,
here we go.
I don't think we need the
tracking issue anymore.
OK, um, that is annoyingly small.
I want to think big thoughts.
Come on, give me longer lines.
OK, this uh, maybe if I minimize this.
I know that the standard won't be
super readable this way, but um.
The code is more important here, OK?
Maybe one more step.
OK, it's kind of tiny.
OK, so Umm, here I'm looking
for that a everything is ugly,
which I'm here I'm not too concerned
about because super wig has written
many peers before and to make sure
that things are mentioned in the right
order and if there's any divergence
between what the standard says and
what the implementation does that I
understand why it diverges sometimes
for some optimization or some internal
unwrapping thing we need to do.
Also I want to highlight things.
Where's my little highlighter?
Here we go.
Um, OK, so we are looking at find last.
That's this one, the Iterator Sentinel.
It's following the standard order.
So we're templated on a forward iterator,
named it.
We need a Sentinel for that iterator.
C Class Ty class PJ is the identity functor.
OK, we have a concept requirement that
it's an indirect binary predicate.
That if we use ranges equal to
on the projected iterator.
Um, and looking at Consti star, uh,
that essentially dereferencing.
The iterator and then running
that through the projection and
then looking at that value.
UM here because it's indirect
binary predicate.
We say Constance star because it's indirect
that we can compare them with equal to.
So that looks right.
And that matches the standard
which says Consti star.
OK, so each of these things should be
no discard because they're observers.
We're looking for the last occurrence,
so we should see six notice cards.
I'll double check that we have this
and then I won't refer to it again.
Um,
also internal helpers are marked notice card.
That's nice.
So two public and then one internal
again here.
Ohh,
we're missing one.
Four find last if operator
paren paren the range form.
This should absolutely be no
discard and it's missing here.
No discard.
OK, so again paranoia increases.
Let me double check um find last two
public functions internal helper.
Find last if one public function
but not the second commented
and then internal helper.
And then find last if not.
Public one again missing here
and then internal helper.
OK, so this one also missing no discard. OK.
Count it. Correct.
OK, going back. Um, pure observer.
So it's no discard.
OK, these things need to be constexpr.
We had long e-mail discussions on
the C Plus standard mailing list
about should you know things in the
STL be marked as no discard eagerly
or should we only do it on the
most dire cases like vector empty?
Lots and lots of discussion.
The committee eventually decided to.
Follow the status quo, which is not mark.
Everything is no discard.
That means that implementations need
to sort of do their own homework as to
whether to mark things as no discard or not,
and provide additional, you know,
quality of implementation as they call it.
We'd love no discarding the STL.
We're up to like 7000 or
something occurrences of it.
I don't even know how many
I'd have to search.
And every everyone is valuable as
long as we avoid false positives,
and this is a clear slam dunk case.
That it's useful.
OK, so constexpr return a
sub range for the iterator,
and this is ranges finglass.
This name is provided by the function object.
Below we take the iterator first,
the Sentinel last.
In this case this is called sent.
That's fine.
What is oh I'm scrolled down.
I'm looking at find Elastic
and I want find last.
I was like why is there a predicate here?
OK find last let me double check context
for subrange it operand Pran it first
ccent OK here we go tonsai ref value.
OK and PJ projection is brace brace.
It's constant on the function.
The function call operator is constant
because the object is constexpr.
OK, and so now let's actually
look at the implementation.
So we are being given a user defined
potentially iterator and Sentinel.
So we want to verify that these
iterators are valid and for
example belong to the same range.
Aren't reversed if they're random access.
We have a helper addl verifier
range that does that.
Now we can remove checking from them
because we know it's a valid range,
or we hope it is.
So we can call our internal helper find
last unchecked down here and we're going to.
Call our unwrap helper,
so there's some common machinery for this.
I won't go into exactly how it works,
but we need to essentially provide
the Sentinel type to the iterator,
and vice versa,
provide the iterator type to the
one that unwraps the Sentinel.
So I actually forget why.
I could go look at the definitions,
but this is the right convention
where we say unwrap it or C and then
move in the first iterator, unwrap,
Sentinel it, move in the Sentinel.
Looks right and they're not constant so
the moving will actually take effect.
We pass value by consti ref and then rods
we pass through this helper *** phone.
This helps with the back end code Gen or did.
I think this may be less necessary now
but I haven't gone through and verified
whether this is still necessary.
This is correct according to
our current conventions.
This returns a sub range which we're going
to use a structured binding to decompose.
This will give us unwrapped.
1st and unwrapped last,
uh, return values.
But then we need to reapply wrapping.
This is the potential layer
of iterator checking.
Give us something like STD vector iterators.
We verify that they're not swapped and that
they belong to the same parent container.
Then we unwrap down to pointers,
run the algorithm real quickly,
and then wrap them back with our
iterator debugging technology.
That's what this is for.
So.
Here we go O we return
a subrange of iterators.
What came in was an iterator
Sentinel pair O we can't reuse sent,
it could be a different type.
That's why we need to make a new
iterator last brace initialized.
Then we're going to seacraft,
which is essentially an assignment,
um 1st, and then move in.
You first, last move you last, it is.
Unclear to me.
Do we need to brace initialize last?
I'm not going to worry about it too much.
I sort of believe that everything should
be initialized and see what's all the time.
In theory it might be possible to
use a singular iterator here because
this is just going to assign.
That's what crap does.
UM, I think we might brace
initialized elsewhere.
This is.
I'm going to check for my own education.
Seek wrap let me just pull
up random occurrences,
which is pretty uncommon that
we make a fresh iterator.
That's why this looks new to me.
Usually we're seeking an existing
iterator and just resetting it.
Let me actually look at the
definition because I think secret
just essentially does an assignment.
Or go ah if, um, it provides a seek to.
Member function, we call it.
Otherwise we do an assignment.
OK, at some point we got this.
I think historically we might have
just always done the assignment,
but in our new machine we've got the seek to.
I think this avoids.
I want to say this avoids unnecessary
debugging logic to like make a
fresh iterator or something.
Um.
No,
this is when you're wrapped you
call seek 2 because these are these
are different types and otherwise
you just do the assignment.
OK, so I think,
I think it historically called
C2 and then later we added this
optimization here.
So when Iterator supports seek two,
they just assign the internal pointer.
Uh.
In the case when you respect iterator
debugging, you're a class type and.
Usually.
Default initialization should be the
same as value initialization, but.
It's certainly correct.
He's value initialization here.
I'm not 100% certain it would be
correct to get rid of those braces.
So this is good. I like it.
OK, seek first to you first,
last to you last and then move them out.
OK, that looks right. Ohh go what?
What is the concern? So um.
What we have here is.
So first here it the iterator first
like the idea behind seacraft is.
Um. Your.
You are taking the
provenance of this iterator.
Keeping it the same like
it has the same container.
And then assigning any new
pointer like iterator value.
And so this default constructed
iterator does not have the
Providence of any container,
and therefore you're right.
Totally missed it.
You're absolutely right,
this has no parent.
This this can't possibly
know what the parent is,
so we really we should be copying it
from first here and then seeking it.
OK, that's like,
so that there was like something
in my brain was telling me that
this was a little weird because
we're making a fresh iterator
here and we almost never do that.
But I totally missed.
Thank you for finding that.
That applies to all of these.
Yeah, this one,
I believe that.
2. I believe that unwrap interior should be.
Letters should have ranges on it.
I think that's our new convention.
Oh, they're qualify it.
Umm, yeah, I think we have an
issue to go apply qualification.
We haven't done that globally yet.
Um, I think most occurrences
here are not yet qualified.
Check leave when I did the
upper unwrap it or changes.
Maybe I didn't. Yeah,
we have tons and tons of unqualified calls,
so I think this is conventional right now.
Um, I think in the future we can just
have a global change to apply this.
Um, we did decide to start
qualifying everything in the STL,
even though it's gonna be horribly verbose.
But I would rather have that done
all at once rather than piece meal.
Yeah, so I think I won't request
changes for that, but absolutely
request changes for the parent.
This indicates a, I would say a
massive hole in our test coverage.
Why are we not finding this?
There should be any use of
vector should find this.
Yeah, go ahead Casey,
I go look at the test coverage.
I want to point out that I've been
looking for trying to figure out why
we don't have this problem already
elsewhere since before Nicole mentioned
that this rewrapping is weird.
We have a helper called Rewrap sub range.
That we use for search in the
algorithm I'm looking at right
now and we desperately looking
for another occurrence to figure
out how we deal with this before.
Yeah like where where we screwed
this up for so we say.
Paper. First pass result.
OK, so here this just demands
that one iterator have the parent,
and then it will make um.
Ohh, this is expecting search into result.
The search in helper to return a sub
range of the unwrapped iterators.
Is that what's going on?
Is is this one essentially.
We haven't rewrapped first here, yeah?
There's always the returns of sub
range of unwrapped iterators,
and rewrap subrange turns that into
a subrange of wrapped iterators.
Oh, I see this is a.
It's taking a whole range here.
OK, and then given a single iterator,
it'll apply that parent to both of them.
OK. Is that what we're doing here?
We've got two unwrapped iterators, OK.
It's just we they they come
out as on actually, no,
they they actually come out as a subrange,
but then they were decomposed here.
So it would actually be simpler
to use Rewrap subrange.
OK, great catch.
Thank you.
Like I can do this pattern anatomy
elsewhere in the algorithms.
It's like we've done it before,
how did we do it?
And that's super big.
Did ask for help with the the
rewrapping because this is new and
it's apparently new to me too.
I'm learning all this new range of stuff.
It's like I know how it used
to historically work.
OK, so let's uh find some context
here and provide this in the comment.
Let's look for the first occurrence
of Rewrap subrange and then I want
to know before I add this comment,
why are we not seeing this in the test?
Is the test machinery which is used
in some of this instantiate or stuff?
Why is this not using like wrapped iterators?
Is it just the test forward instantiated
just doesn't use vector iterators
ever or anything that behaves like it?
It uses test colon,
colon iterator from range,
range support, range algorithm support?
And they don't have a problem with
rewrapping things. In this manner.
OK, so there's no sense of.
The original iterator has apparent that
distinguishes it from value initialized.
There is not, and there ought to be. Do we?
There is not, and there ought to be.
We should all file an issue for that.
OK, awesome. Thank you.
Expand that bit of coverage in the range.
Yeah,
and that that the nice thing about that is,
yeah it'll it'll be annoying to write.
Um,
because the the parent checking
logic is always annoying.
But once we write it,
it will provide validation to everything,
which is like zillions and zillions
of branches algorithms going through
this very useful instantiated
machinery and prevent further problems
of this nature from occurring.
OK, so thanks for finding that.
Let me find the Rewrap subrange.
This is search N. Let me get here.
This is saying size Sentinel fours any
one of these better than the others.
This one is simpler, the unsized one,
because we don't need to
separately compute the Dist.
So I'll give that as the example.
Hit Y to get a permalink,
and then there we go.
OK. So let's go up.
And go down because I made the
mistake of expanding stuff.
OK, so here's where it is.
There we go.
OK. Expand this. OK, so. Nicole.
Noticed um.
A major problem here, um.
The argument um. It.
No, that's a parameter,
the parameter. It. First um.
Is a wrapped iterator with a.
Parent. In the general case.
Like a vector. Federator.
But it. But the freshly constructed.
Let's say let's be proper and say
value initialized. Um, it last.
Um has no parent.
Uh. Therefore um.
Calling um, seek wrapped.
I just copy this whole thing.
There's no there for yet,
ccrap last. You've moved you last.
Doesn't have any parent information
to add. Um. Causeway you last is
a raw pointer. When unwrapped.
For example, not saying it's
a raw pointer all the time.
Just provide an example.
Um, so we end up.
Returning um incompatible.
Iterators.
Let's see.
Going to provide credit here. Thanks, Nicole.
And it's time for ask points.
Yeah. And then. Can you see notes that the?
Ranges instantiated or machinery used
by our tests could have detected this,
but currently. Doesn't have validation.
Or. Matching parents the way
that vector iterators do. Umm.
Instead, the granges test machinery
has its own test iterators.
Is filing an issue?
Um to add. Such coverage, um.
So it doesn't need to be added in this PR.
Casey explained that the
proper way to fix this issue.
Let me Scroll down. Oh no,
that's not going to get me.
That is to call.
Rewrap subrange. I'll verify I'm
not typing this, um as other
ranges algorithms do. Example.
I mean, look at the example for context.
Um. Yeah, so it's basically
you provide a single iterator.
I'm trying to describe it in human terms.
Uh, for super wig, provide a parented
iterator and an unwrapped sub range and
it will make a wrapped subrange. OK.
This is given a parented iterator
and an unwrapped subrange. Which?
Is simpler. Since we don't need to decompose
it with a structured binding and returns a.
Wrapped subbranch um.
Occurs below in all. Algorithms.
I'll grow them over this.
OK awesome uh proofread uh Nicole uh,
noticed major problem here that parameter
it first is wrapped iterator with a parent
in the general case like a vector iterator.
But the freshly value initialized
it last brace brace has no parent.
Seacraft last you move stood move
you last doesn't have any parent
information to add because you last is
our pointer when unwrapped for example.
So we end up returning
incompatible iterators.
Thanks Nicole for finding this amazing
issue that I totally missed on first glance.
Casey notes that the range is
instantiated machine are used by
our tests could have detected.
But currently does not have
validation for matching parents the
way the vector iterators do.
Instead,
the range is test machinery
has its own test iterators.
He's filing an issue to add such coverage,
so it doesn't need to be added in this PR,
Casey explained that the proper way
to fix this issue is to call Rewrap
subrange as other ranges algorithms do.
Example.
So call the unwrapped version
that matches and then.
We can just return here.
So it would basically crunch these,
uh,
what is that 5 lines with wrapping ignore
wrapping down to two ignoring wrapping,
which is great.
This is given a parented iterator
and an unwrapped sub range,
which is simpler since we don't need
to decompose it with the structured
binding and returns a ramped subrange.
OK. Add or view comment excellent.
OK, so, uh, going onwards.
Uh, the rest should hopefully be um.
Very systematic. Uh.
We are looking at the find last
for the one that takes a range.
So template forward range R or range class
TIE class PGA identity requires indirect
binary predicate range equal to projected,
the iterator type for the
range and the prog consti star.
We got the notice card on this
one constexpr Bard subrange TR.
Operator Renren take range
ref ref range constant,
high ref value J rod is brace
brace constant on the object.
OK, so going to be doing.
I'm going to ignore all the wrapping stuff.
Now we get ranges begin from the range.
And that's auto. First we're going
to call the unchecked helper with.
Unwrap range hitter for the
range stood move you first.
This is uh, it's not.
Obviously not new, but um,
I don't remember what this does.
I've got tons of usage of it.
OK, so you give it a range,
you give it the original range type.
And.
Why is this special?
Ohh because it passes the Sentinel type.
OK, because the unwrap thing.
As I mentioned earlier,
the unwrap ITER requires the Sentinel type.
But it would be annoying to have to say
Sentinel T range all the time when we
just could just say range by itself. OK.
And we check that the thing that we're
giving it is the iterator type for the range.
So there's a bit of validation in addition
to the convenience of grabbing Sentinel.
So that's what this is doing. OK.
Uh, so we unwrap.
Uh, move stood move first.
It's not constant. It's good.
Past the unchecked end for the range,
give the value constant ref,
pass the projection.
Then we won't decompose this.
We'll use the Rewrap subrange, excuse me.
And then return it. Good.
OK, private helper template iterator,
Sentinel, Ty PJ.
Notice guard.
This is static because it doesn't
need anything from the class. Uh,
Constexpr helper returning subrange of it.
Uh this is the unchecked.
I said Ohh there because I'm
like what are we looking at?
This is the unchecked algorithm helper.
So it here is unchecked.
So it's a returning a
sub range of unchecked.
It makes me mildly nervous
to use the same type here.
I think this is entirely
consistent with precedent.
So the principle that I prefer to
follow is same names for same things,
different names for different things.
Because the way I always explain it,
in templated code,
we kind of have no type system.
This is not entirely true
now that we have concepts.
So concepts provide a type system over types.
But. Not to the level that you know
actual type serve for variables.
Um, and especially when you're
just rewriting helper wrappers
that aren't incredibly concept
constrained or static asserted.
You can just type anything.
Like you can give things a name and
then pass it to some other thing,
and then that name of that type parameter.
That template type template type
parameter is sort of all that
is telling you what it does and
how to use it and mismatches.
Yeah, maybe they'll cause.
Tyler errors,
but without you know definition checking.
Um,
if you are passing around like an
unchecked type or checked type,
and then you pass it to something where
the name suggests that it's unchecked,
well,
you get confused about what
you're looking at.
Just the other day and we found
a bug where we were sending
the wrong type to some helper
machinery where we were sending a
wrapped type which could be like
a vector iterator instead of an
unwrapped type like a raw pointer,
and then that caused some
optimization code to not activate.
Properly.
Um.
So it helps when writing heavily
template code to be extremely disciplined
about having descriptive names.
And then if you change the nature of
a thing like unwrapping or adding a
pointer to something or changing to unsigned,
or.
All these transformations we can do
at each layer of templated machinery,
change the name that's being used
if you know it's always going to be
like the unchecked version or the
unsigned version or something like that.
Here, I'm a little bit uncomfortable
in going on this.
Side um.
Cause we've got a wrapped iterator being
passed to the user algorithm, we unwrap it.
And.
In this helper overload here,
this helper algorithm not an overload.
Um,
instead of being named something like you,
it which would signal, hey,
this is the unwrapped iterator.
It's just named it so it's reusing the name.
But for something that is
different makes me mildly nervous.
Now, it's not incorrect,
and I think it is actually
consistent with Preston,
so I'm not going to request changes here,
I'm just going to double check.
But it's pretty conventional.
Yeah.
Ideally I'd like to change the Convention,
but I certainly don't think we would
want to change this in this PR.
And it's probably not even I'm.
I'm just nervous because I've seen it occur.
And The thing is,
is the sort of thing that you can get
away with like almost all the time.
Every once in a while it gets you.
So I worry about it because I try to
make code as defragged free as possible.
So like, here's an example,
the search engine size thing
that we look for the rewrap.
And yeah, this is just given it.
Even though it in general is unchecked
O OK consistent with precedent.
I wish the precedent were
a little bit different,
but it is certainly not
worth commenting here.
OK. O template on unwrapped iterator
CTI PJ notice card static on the
object constexpr subrange it.
This is the unwrapped version.
Fine. Last unchecked it first.
See last constar value PJ project
it's static so it doesn't need
to be constant and cannot be.
In fact, this doesn't need to be concept
constrained because it's just a helper.
But we do static cert that all the
concepts we expect hold in test machinery.
STL internal Static Cert expands only to.
Static assert in our tests that we're
dealing with a forward iterator,
that C is a Sentinel for it,
and then we've got the indirect
binary predicate thing.
Um.
Thing that I'm thinking about is for
the equal 2 do we say range is double
colon or do we use the capital ranges?
I don't want to look at Navas.
UH-4 the names of the parameter we do
just say lane range is double colon.
For function calls we say
under score capital ranges,
but here this is an unambiguous.
OK, that's fine. Is it ranges corn
corn equal to and not just two?
Uh, correct it is ranges double colon
equal to um, because that one is uh,
it's not templated.
The classic equal to does have template
arguments, even though you can give
it the diamond my diamond that.
Makes its function call operator templated,
but the ranges version of the predicate
is sort of the way the predicate
should have always been defined.
They've got that transparent
functionality baked into them,
so that's why this uses the range of thing.
I think they might do something else.
Did they have some other fancy machinery
that the classic one doesn't have?
Actually don't know. Let's check.
Same thing? I think so.
They have concept constraints instead
of return types feeding constraints,
but no, they're not that much.
OK. Uh, what was that, Nicole,
you you were saying something?
Does ranges last do the?
Great thing with pointers that like.
Ohh yeah yeah four non flat memory
yeah I think yeah I think that
is specified in the standard.
Not that it makes a difference for
replication month of my life figuring
out how to write the standard's to
make sure that all of the ranges,
ordering functions and all this stood
ordering functions did the same thing
with pointers and that they all
observed a consistent ordering and
I still didn't get it quite right.
And Gaspar,
Ashman and W.
821 had to fix one last plug in.
The wording is dead last void do
the right thing?
Because I feel like I heard
something about how studless void
doesn't impose a strict order or
a total ordering on pointers.
The issue. I'm sorry, what was that Casey,
I was talking over you.
It does now do the correct thing.
Yes it does. OK, what's funny is that
violates my my original design for the
diamonds because the philosophy for the
diamonds was you get what operator less
than gives you no extra intelligence.
And I was like, OK,
well if you say let's diamond for pointers
you're going to get what you you deserve.
But I guess they went in
and enhanced it anyways.
So I guess that's fine it again
it doesn't make a difference for.
Our implementation.
Are there actually any actual
implementations of C + + 14 for?
For my architecture.
I don't believe so.
Um, uh, in fact, uh,
I think I could be wrong.
I think all good news systems say that hey,
we just expect flat 32 bit spaces are
larger and that would be the systems
where you would expect the segmented
to possibly be an issue because they
cover such diverse family of computers.
Certainly for no window systems,
windows is like, yeah,
everything is going to be flat memory.
There has been some talk of keeping around
all that, oh, we could handle segmented.
Memory pointers,
things like that for future architectures
where maybe your address space is 128 bit,
but the 1st 64 bit tells you like you know,
what kind of storage you're in or whatever.
That's why they've kept that language around.
My understanding, but I don't
think it's actually a concern for.
Any real systems?
I forget what Constexpr does.
If Constexpr lets you compare
the addresses of things,
I think it doesn't.
Right now they have to exist
at the same memory.
If you try to compare addresses
of unrelated things, it says whoa,
I can't do this because it's unspecified.
So in practice, it's the there's.
There's no no work needed from implementers.
Uh, OK. So returning from the
land of comparisons, uh equal to
projected iterator T range project,
we looked at the signature. OK, const.
Umm. And then we grab ranges.
Begin first, find lesson checked,
unwrap. OK, I looked at this.
Ohh wait no I was I was down in
fine last unchecked. Here we go. OK.
My brain is now resuming.
Uh, indirect binary predicate range
is equal to projected at PJ star.
OK, so here is where we see the.
Multiple implementations of the
algorithm that I originally talked about.
So this says if constexpr,
um if the iterator and the Sentinel
are bidirectional and common,
meaning that they're the same type
and we're bidirectional so we
can March backward from the end,
then we can have the cool fast algorithm.
So for auto result is last
past the end iterator.
Henry read it because we were working
with an inclusive exclusive range.
Result is last O.
We're going to want to.
And I can see it on the the next line
we're going to want to pre decrement
result and then look at the element there.
So that's valid for the final iterator
because we point past the end.
So when we decrement we get
the actual last element.
But if first and last are identical,
we're talking about an empty range.
We do not want to decrement anymore.
So we want to keep going as long as
the result is not equal to first,
because when it is,
we've exhausted all the elements.
So that is the correct condition.
I always like to think about my
binary conditions, especially or my.
Boundary conditions,
especially when marching backwards,
because everything is topsy turvy
and it's easy to get confused with
off by ones like reverse iterator is
just a recipe for confusion here.
We're not directly using reverse iterator,
but we're doing the same sort of thing.
Um, and then we've got a fancy update.
So there's no plus, plus or minus,
minus here.
O as I mentioned we dereference
pre decrement of result.
We look at it through the
projection by invoking.
It stood invoke and then if that is operator
equal equal the value then return stuff,
return stood move the result
and stood move last which is.
This here, and we can do that because
even though this is a Sentinel type,
we have verified that it is common.
It's the same type as the iterator,
so we can move it out.
OK.
And then if we don't find it, return last,
last as mandated by the standard here?
OK, that looks good. Um.
I was quickly thinking of um.
It is interesting that we go and define
find last separately and not just in
terms of find last if with an equal 2.
I think this is consistent
with what we do elsewhere.
We spam out a definition of separate
algorithms rather than saying oh,
we can just implement this in terms
of like the equal to PRED because
it does kind of save 1 inlined
invocation is better in debug mode.
Interestingly,
this is not the approach that we took
with the classic algorithms where
we did unify them a long time ago.
With um, predicates like if we look at uh,
what's a good example? Um.
Try to think.
Something that compares find find.
I'll do it.
Why am I thinking hard about
look for a pretty, uh uh,
precedent when there's just fined.
Of course find it occurs in
Asian places in the STL.
I wanna look at algorithm.
Or it might actually be in no,
it's an extra utility.
Love to play the game of word.
We define this thing.
OK, here we go.
Um.
Oh no, we would need we would need
a Lambda because fine, take it.
It's a predicate versus a value.
So we actually do define separate things.
We would need to bind like a.
OK, so it wouldn't be trivial to unify them.
We we could with the Lambda, but we
have historically not done that, so OK,
so that's why we define all separate thing.
OK, we're discovering things.
OK, so that's good for the eye case.
Otherwise we're either not
bidirectional so we're forward only,
or they are different types,
so the next case is well.
What if you have the same
iterator and Sentinel types?
Which would imply that they
are weaker than bidirectional.
So forward only then let's do
the forward only algorithm.
But we can assume commonality
that they're the same type.
So here's the forward version.
We have auto results as last because
we are going to need to preserve that.
We will need to return it sometimes,
actually all the time.
Yes, all the time. Um.
So result will be the thing that we March,
um. Ohh not, sorry,
not March backwards, marching forwards.
Um, result is the best one we've found
found so far, the one that matches.
So if we don't find anything,
we want to return last, last.
So that's why we initialize it to last,
correct?
And then we've already initialized first
as long as first has not reached last.
We're going to step forward 1st every time,
and then look at Derek 1st through
the projections to invoke.
If that's equal to the value we want,
update result,
set it to the current value 1st,
and then when we're done, returns to.
Move results to move last.
That achieves this.
Perfect.
OK, otherwise, um,
we're not MIDI common and we're
not coming up.
So that means we're looking at um,
right?
This is if you're bidirectional and common.
This is interesting. Is there a
fourth case that we're missing here?
So I'm mentally working through
the matrix of possibilities.
I need to sketch it out,
cause four things is apparently too
much for my brain to handle at once.
Without seeing it in front of me,
O we've got, uh, bite eye we've got common.
Binary, so yes, yes.
Make a little table yes, no no yes no no.
OK, so if the range is byte I and common,
so the same types,
then we've already handled that handle.
This is the byte icon in case.
OK, Umm, let's come back.
So if you're not both of them,
then we've got one of these cases.
So all these elses when same as Iterator,
Sentinel, then that would catch
this case not by dye, but common.
So this is the handled.
Same as. As itsy don't know,
I'm putting effort in getting
all the underscores right.
OK, otherwise this else here
is handling 2 cases and that's
what my brain was asking.
OK,
we know they're not common.
Right, and yet not common.
This would be the case of like.
Let me see if I get this right. Um.
It could be as simple as a stood list
iterator and a stood list constant iterator.
Is that right?
Where they are usable as a Sentinel,
but they aren't exactly the same type.
This is something that the
classic STI CK C nodding,
so I think I've got it right.
This is something that the
classic STL would not handle.
It would say whoa, you're giving me
two different types as the iterator.
I can't deduce what template
argument you would want to fail at.
Compile time ranges handles this,
which is nice.
But it means that checks for
like same as in common will be
false because you can't produce,
you know, the same type.
You could convert them to a type,
but they're not literally the same type.
It's odd that common is used there
even though they do have a common type,
but anyways, the Bidi case.
Ohh you switch back to the code.
Yeah,
sorry,
I think.
OK, uh, because there's no minus minus here.
That's what my brain I
I quickly scan forward.
I was like, hey, there's no minus, minus.
Shouldn't we have like the case where,
yeah, we can use the Sentinel,
but can't we use that advanced thing
to get an actual iterator to the end,
possibly instantly, and then decrement?
The question is,
is it worth the trouble to do so?
Right. Is that going to be more
efficient than making a single pass
using the forward iterator algorithm?
Yeah, well I think it will be more
efficient for a random access, right?
I think if there are sized and random access,
we should probably also have.
In that case. Because if you have like.
I don't know a vector iterator
and a vector concentrator exactly.
You have to go through all
of the entire thing to find.
Exactly. Yeah, because we we essentially
can keep the, the efficiency um,
so is that is that what so you said?
Uh, random access sized uh.
I'm trying to think what is the exact
criterion that we want to ask for where
we could use the minus minus case.
So I guess we have it would need obviously
need to buy dye but what about random
and obviously contiguous we don't,
we don't care about and then?
Sized. Unsized.
I'm trying to think which ones?
Unsigned. Unsized.
Which ones can we do anything for so.
If you are by dye only, then.
Even if you're sized, um,
if you have an iterator and a Sentinel,
even if you know the size of that,
you need to March forward.
To find the actual last iterator
and then possibly go and decrement.
That doesn't seem like in general it
would be a win it that it does like.
There's a tradeoff here that is
hard to make without knowing actual
types because the algorithm of
March that Bidi iterator forward
either counting with the size or
just until you reach the Sentinel
and then start inspecting backwards.
You would end up having to pay and
increments and then order until
you find the actual thing.
Uh, decrements, essentially.
Um,
but you get to save a whole bunch
of predicate invocations,
uh,
because you've skipped over invoking
the predicate and the projection
on all those initial ones.
So you do pay some extra traversals.
You pay like twice as many
traversals in the order of from
the end to the found element,
but you get a avoid a whole bunch of
predicate invocations and projections,
which is potentially nice.
So I'm kind of tempted to say,
hey if you're if you're bite,
we should just always advance to the
end because the the usual idea in
the STL is that iterator operations
are cheap and things like predicate
invocations are expensive ish.
Which is why like complexity
requirements are given in terms of
number of invocations of predicate
and they don't ever talk about,
OK, exactly how many times can
you increment iterators and stuff.
Certainly it may not always be a
win in wall clock time when the
traversals are expensive as they
actually kind of are for linked lists
because everyone kills the cache.
Um, and if the predicate invocation is cheap?
But it seems like it could be valuable
now in the case of random access.
If you are random access,
it doesn't matter sized or unsigned,
you can always uhhh no no, it's got to be.
Random access and size Sentinel 4
because if you have random access
and if you have a size Sentinel
you get that distance then you do
plus and you're done.
If you have random access and unsized
Sentinel like I'm looking through
a string that's null terminated,
then that actually it doesn't
help you that it's random access,
you must traverse the whole thing,
so random and sized.
Um, can't jump to the end instantly,
so this is definitely the case.
Random in size is definitely a case
where you'd want to do this for by die.
Doesn't matter whether you're sized or not.
That's the interesting question.
What do you what do you think
after having talked through?
The performance pros and cons?
I kind of think you're right.
Since we're almost definitely going to
have to seek all the way to the end anyway.
That we're going to have to evaluate
all of those predicates at least once.
It's probably worth the trouble to
to evaluate the Sentinel predicates
all the way through the range,
one-on-one,
traverse,
and then maybe minimize the number of.
User predicates that we have to evaluate.
So I agree that it's probably worth the
trouble to have a plain by diversion
Abidi not common version and to have
a random in size Sentinel slash size
range is another pretty obvious win.
But I think we were going to handle
those in the caller by having the
caller transform random and sized
into the same as case, right?
By having the caller find the end iterator.
And pass in begin iterator
and iterator to this helper.
Ohh, really interesting.
Yeah,
because that way you don't have
to deal with the size.
The size range case is the weird 1 right?
We might have a sized range whose iterator
in Sentinel or at size Sentinel 4.
So to deal with that will either end
up having to pass a size into this
function or get rid or deal with
the size problem before we call it.
So it would be pretty simple I think
in the McAuley starting the caller.
To say if that we have random access in size,
find the final iterator and
call this one helper with the.
First and last iterator values.
OK, so slightly different forms for the um.
This would want size Sentinel 4.
This would want size range.
Yeah. OK.
And then have a case the bite I
bite I bite I yes come in no case
that does the essentially pretec.
Right. And then that would go ahead.
Given the implementation of advance.
The bidai non common case.
Would be exactly the same
as the size Sentinel 4K.
OK, yeah, yeah.
That's why I was wondering.
Like doesn't advance with this for us.
It's gonna use whatever the get
final iterator helper, yeah.
Grants, right? The range is
one could be more efficient.
We have another helper called another
ugly helper called get final iterator
value or just get final iterator.
That takes a range or an iterator and
Sentinel, I think. And figures out the.
Oh yeah, wow. Even does the unwrapping.
OK, so this says, um,
if they're the same type after unwrapping.
Then just take that last
thing and then unwrap it.
Otherwise use ranges next on the
appropriately unwrapped thing.
OK, right. So this is what we
were just random access in size
will obviously do the O1 version.
So yeah, this has the smarts wrapped
up inside of it because this problem
of course appeared in other rounds.
Would we be able to do this
in the helper algorithm?
Would would each call site need to
do it with the caller need to do it?
I think it's very simple here.
It's best if the caller does it still, yeah.
OK. And we were going to do this because
there's a there's a range overload.
Arsenal. Yeah, I see.
Well, it's actually overloaded.
OK, why? Why did I not see that here?
Ohh because it's right. Pull up.
OK oh oh and this. Here we go.
The range one says oh if it's a
common range then we got more cases.
OK, so this this logic is actually
quite annoying to do from scratch,
but it's already done.
There's even another overload there if we
have a range and amid iterator from it.
Yeah yeah because that would say
even even more. The right one. OK.
Umm, it's sort of hard to describe.
I guess we could just give the name
of the algorithm and say here figure
this out super quick and then.
They can ask if there's any
question about what to do.
I think that the press should probably
say if the if the range slash iterator
type is at least bidirectional,
we should use get final iterator and pass
the result into the unchecked. Helper.
Which is what feinglass unchecked.
Sorry and define last OK,
but that that would basically request
and if constexpr in the callers right?
Saying if constexpr bidirectional
then do this thing.
OK, that's that's a lot of complexity,
but I guess it could be worth it.
I mean, it's obviously worth it.
It's only one layer of if constexpr and it
avoids wasting effort for the forward case,
which is something we want to avoid.
Yeah, that's a good point.
And I see we do do this elsewhere
like in rotate unchecked we're like
hey if constexpr bidirectional
iterator of course rotates you know
special but it also needs to do some
special stuff here we have got a
lot of calls so a lot of precedent.
I'm just looking is there any
precedent for this sort of we handle
forward iterators but if it's by
die then we'll step up and use.
I don't immediately see anything like that.
So this is sort of a new case, um.
Yeah, it looks like whenever we call it,
we already know we're ran or Abidi.
At least in most of these.
Of course, many still algorithms
already want random labidi.
That's this rotate one.
That's the only one I'm seeing.
OK, I'll suggest it anyways.
Um, OK else here you can tell them
to figure it out, and if they want,
they can figure it out by asking
us to explain it. Blame Casey.
He's the one who wrote all this stuff.
I don't want to write a book
about how to do this right now,
but ask Casey if you can't figure it out.
There's an exercise left to the Casey, OK.
So there are.
Four possible combinations of
bodye and common hike Kitty.
The remaining 15 minutes of this review
will just be STL making cat noises.
Possible combinations of Bodie and common um.
Leave um. Above the. Umm.
Buy dye.
And common.
We've handled. By dye and common. And.
Ah, I'll just say forward. And. Common.
Hereby bite I really mean bidai
and stronger, but it's fine.
I think that's clear
and forward and common.
Uh, cases above, um.
But I come in forward comment
the remaining cases. Umm.
That would be. Bidai.
Uncommon. And. Forward on common. Are.
Ah.
Are possible here.
Um, the implementation. Below.
Trying to make clear what I'm
referring to in this else.
Brace else brace just made me else block.
Um, is the only possible implementation?
For. Or non comment. Course. Umm.
However for the buy dye non common case.
This is invoking the. Uh, this is using.
The forward only algorithm.
Which invokes the predicate and.
Let me put in the order
of actual invocation,
projection and predicate.
On every single. Element.
It would be possible. To.
Find the last iterator.
And then use the buy dye algorithm.
Umm. 4 by die only iterators.
This would pay and traversals only.
Followed by order.
Distance. From result to.
Last um. Traversals. I see.
Let's say backwards traversals.
Projections.
Predicates. That's not a.
All that isn't a 100% guaranteed win.
It is likely to be better,
especially for expensive predicates and.
When we are fortunate.
To find the result. Near the last.
I'll just say the last um.
And if the uh.
Uh, let's say argument.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to avoid saying input
because that has its own meaning.
If the arguments are random and sized,
we can jump to the end.
Instantly, um, this scenario.
Could occur.
When the Iterator Sentinel pair. Is.
Vector. Iterator cons iterator for example.
OK, so where is the thing?
Like I heard us um.
There's a helper to.
Make this easier.
Uh, get final iterator on wrapped um.
Should I just say, see existing usage
and then talk about how we would want the?
Callers to detect bite eye.
Use this and then.
That would so if the callers say if bite
I use um get final iterator unwrapped
and then call this unchecked function,
that would end up being absorbed by the
byte I common case then is that correct?
Because get finite iterator unwrapped
would convert that Sentinel which is a
different type to the common case right?
OK, um. The um callers?
Iterator, Sentinel and Range
can have if constexpr.
For.
By dye or stronger iterators.
And use.
Yet final iterator and ramped
before calling the unchecked helper.
Then. The. But I common.
Case in the unchecked. Helper.
Would absorb this scenario, so a.
4th. Case would not.
Need to be added.
Please see existing calls to.
All I want, I wanna think thoughts that
are bigger than four lines at a time.
Here we go. All this all this
complicated cpaws totally fine.
The moment the UI annoys me,
I'm like her. Angry cat face.
Please see existing calls to
get final iterator unwrapped.
Uh, or bug Casey? Ask Casey.
Uh, for. Assistance. As he has volunteered.
Yeah. OK, always near the end of our review
slot and I'm almost done with this algorithm.
The remaining ones will be very similar,
so I think we found the all
the interesting issues here.
There are four possible combinations
of Vida uncommon we've handled.
I'm checking my table here Bidi and
common and forward and common cases above.
The remaining cases by Dynon common and
forward non common are possible here.
The information below in the South
block is the only possible amputation
for four non common of course.
However, for the binary non common
case this is using the forward only
algorithm which invokes the projection
and predicate on every single element.
It would be possible to find the
last iterator and then use the dye
algorithm for byte I only iterators
this would pay N traversals.
Only followed by order
distance from result to last,
backwards traversals,
projections, predicates.
While that isn't 100% guaranteed win,
it is likely to be better,
especially for expensive predicates
and when we're fortunate to find
the result near the last and if
the arguments are random and sized
we can jump to the end instantly.
The scenario could occur when the
Iterator Sentinel pair is vector
iterator constant iterator for example.
Fortunately there's a helper
to make this easier.
Get final iterator unwrapped
the callers Iterator,
Sentinel and range can have if
constexpr for bodye or stronger.
Iterators and use get final
iterator unwrapped before
calling the unchecked helper.
Then the Bidi common case and the unchecked
helper would absorb this scenario,
so a fourth case would not need to be added.
Please see existing calls to get final
iterator unwrapped or ask Casey for
assistance as he has volunteered to help.
OK.
OK, so let's validate this forward
case before calling in today.
Um, we've got it. Result.
This is the unchecked form, so we don't.
Worry about the parent thing here.
Um, value initialized loop forever.
Look at the first iterator
through the projection stored.
Invoke if that's equal to
the value that we want.
Remember result is first.
There should be a new line between
Unchained gift if statements style.
There should be a new line between
non chained if statements to make
it clear where they begin and end.
OK, so remembering the result.
Sorry for scrolling up and down.
Remember the result.
We're looping forever.
If the thing that we're looking at is
the value then record it in the result.
If not then don't update.
Then after a new line step forward
first if we have reached the last.
Then that's bad. Ah.
I'm saying ohh here because I'm like,
have we verified that
there's actually an element?
We have not,
right?
This could totally be empty like this
input could absolutely be empty.
With no guarantee that we can look
at an element here, so that's a bug.
Yep. Interesting that this was
not caught by test coverage.
Why don't we pass them D ranges?
I guess it depends on the algorithm, um.
But that does indicate missing tests.
I think we do have an empty
range coverage test. Yeah. OK.
I'm going to comment on this.
Copied the test code from yeah OK,
this is deep dereferencing.
First um. Without a guarantee.
Or just dereferencing first,
but we haven't.
Umm. I'll just say,
but the range could be empty.
Umm. This also indicates.
Um. Missing test coverage.
Do is uh, should I mention that
result should probably be initialized
to last to handle this case?
Because like we got this right?
Here, yeah, this loop is is.
Uh, well, it's the last because
it's not a common iterator.
It's not like it's not.
Ohh, you're right, yeah.
So we we essentially need a um.
A case here, I I hear your cat.
Um, there's a.
The cat is annoyed that we haven't
verified that the the range is not empty.
Um, so we say we essentially
need a test coverage for non
common ranges that are empty.
Ranges that are empty.
I forgot this one case or
something like that, yeah.
OK, so this is actually a
slightly larger problem.
I'm going to cancel this and
comment on a large chunk of code.
OK, so um, this is dereferencing first,
but the range could be empty.
Will need to actually just.
In general, if we never find something,
we need to return last. Do we ever?
That's interesting, yeah.
Both initialized Iterator comma first.
It's attempted to be handled here,
but it's conditional on
if we hit the last here.
Um, I don't know.
Ohh, that's horrible.
Yeah, this does take advantage of
the fact that value initialized
iterator should at least be equal,
but but this is not valid for
arbitrary iterators because.
Assuming you have an iterator that.
Doesn't participate in unwrapping
and yet enforces.
Same parent or same domain?
This is trying to compare value
initialized to a non value initialized.
We can't do that.
You can't do and everybody thinks
you can't do it, but you can't.
Yeah.
And the the worst part or the
most subtle part is that.
Most the time you'll actually get
away with this because we unwrap all
of our cool layers of machinery and
the four pointers will handle this.
But you still shouldn't do this.
All the standard iterators do this,
but the concepts don't require it.
Yeah, we yeah,
we recently spent hours explaining
this to herb for CPP 2,
if I remember correctly.
OK,
so let's see so many things to explain here.
This is dereferencing,
so there's the.
When I when I make two does
I write them in all caps.
As a reminder, don't actually
hit publish before doing this
value and then test coverage.
OK, so this is dereferencing first,
but the range could be empty.
In the. Case.
Said. In the uh. Let me begin
by saying several issues here.
All related. Is directing first,
but the range could be empty,
um when we don't find a result. Um.
For example, because the range is empty.
Or it's not empty.
I'm gonna exhaustively mention
all the possible cases,
but nothing matched.
OK, value in it. Uh, we need to return.
Let me just refer to the standard's here.
Last, last. Race.
Last, last um. There's.
Code below that attempts to.
Achieve this with.
Blah.
Umm. But that is not allowed by
the iterator requirements. Umm.
Value initialized iterators.
Are comparable with guaranteed equal.
To other value initialized iterators.
But they cannot be compared.
To. Other iterators.
Ones with parents.
Should I say that I'll just say
other iterators? I don't want to
bring the parent thing in here.
I'll mention parenthetically, um.
In practice, um.
Still iterators, uh, won't.
Detect this issue.
Because they participate in.
Unwrapping. So. By the time we reach.
This code. Um.
The debug checks that would detect it.
I've been unwrapped away.
The standard.
Fire.
And it is totally possible. For user
defined iterators to reject or two.
I'm trying to avoid confusing negation
to lack any unwrapping machinery.
And simultaneously enforce the rule.
Against comparing value.
Initialize try will say parenthood
with parented. Iterators.
Um, OK, and then should I mention, yeah,
I just mentioned this test coverage.
Um, this indicates a lack.
Of a test coverage.
Or I guess I don't really care
about the the value in it thing
for the test coverage because
that's kind of obscure the the the.
The issue you filed about having
test coverage with the parent
iterator is may improve that,
but at a minimum I do want to see
test coverage for empty ranges.
This indicates a lack of test
coverage for empty ranges.
Year. That are, um,
this fundamental one would be used
after this optimization is done for.
Was it forward? Non common? Yes.
Four non common in this case.
OK, a lot of bullet points, um.
We're like OK, final issue of the
day and then it ends up being long.
Um, several issues here are related.
This is dereferencing first,
but the range could be empty.
When we don't find a result,
for example because the range is empty
or it's not empty but nothing matched,
we need to return less last.
There's code below that attempts to achieve
this with if result is it brace brace.
But that is not allowed by
the iterator requirements.
Value initialized iterators are
comparable and guaranteed equal to
other value initialized iterators,
but they cannot be compared
to other iterators.
In practice, iterators won't detect
this issue because they participated in.
Unwrapping.
So by the time we reach this code,
the debug checks that would detect
it have been unwrapped away.
However,
the standard however the standards
requirements still apply and it's
totally possible for user defined
iterators to lack any unwrapping
machinery and simultaneously enforce
the rule against comparing value
initialized with parented iterators.
This indicates a lack of test
coverage for empty ranges for
non common in this case.
OK,
so this whole case needs a significant
overhaul so I'm not going to
spend too much time reviewing it,
it is trying to do the right thing.
Move result move first OK Umm
very semi for the class and then
export inline Casper fine less
than fine last construct tag.
OK so we got through we got through
fine last who find last if fun and
fine last not should be very similar.
In fact when I go and re review this
after changes have been made I think
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna after checking find last I'm
going to take find last if and find
last if not I'm going to copy them
into separate editor tabs and VS code.
I'm just going to dip them because
they should look very very similar
with only the stuff around, um,
how we test the predicate varying and any
other variants I would want to look at.
So other than that should be,
and that would also detect things like notice
card appearing on something not the other.
Of course,
it won't detect things that
are common to all of them,
but if we review find last first,
then find last as the first thing we look at,
then we can have high confidence that
the rest will be appropriately updated.
OK, so that's good.
I'm not going to mark this as
entirely viewed and I'll come back
and review test coverage later.
We know that.
We know that the test will need to be
expanded for the issues that we found.
Um, so here, just glancing at this,
this test does seem plausible.
Um,
it does need to be expanded
somewhat like I can see,
like we don't have missing,
we don't have empty range of
coverage because we always
use a haystack of three things.
It makes me a little nervous
that this is so small.
There are at least found enough found
cases so the the the reason why I said it
makes me nervous is we've had a couple
of other issues where we have found bugs.
For example because the only things
we passed to 1 algorithm were like
less than 32 elements and we had a
bug that occurred as soon as we had 33
elements or more because there was a
there was a check in the code that hey
if it's small use like insertion sort.
So net most code doesn't have.
Excuse me.
Most code doesn't have that
sort of dependency on length,
so here I don't specifically believe that
we need like huge haystacks or anything,
but we were certainly missing empty cases.
It doesn't immediately occur to me whether
there's anything else we're missing here,
but I'll come back and review this later.
OK. I'll go ahead and submit this review.
Uh, I'll just uh yeah, I think this
is definitely request changes, so.
There we go. And I think that does it.
So thank you for, uh, sticking with
us until the end of this code review.
I believe this one,
this one will be our last of 2022.
So we will see you next year.
Thanks for watching.